my Lord's ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of all my family
I can only offer the most heartfelt
thanks
for your condolences
I'm here today at a time of great
personal sorrow as we Mark the death of
my beloved mother
after a life most Faithfully dedicated
to the duty to which she had been called
it is fitting that we should meet at
Hillsborough which my mother knew so
well
and in whose beautiful rose garden she
always took such pleasure
in the years since she began her long
life of Public Service
my mother saw Northern Ireland passed
through
momentous
and historic changes
through all those years she never ceased
to pray for the best of times for this
place and its people
whose stories she knew whose Sorrows our
family had felt
and for whom she had a great affection
and regard
my mother fell deeply I know the
significance of the role she herself
played in bringing together Those whom
history had separated and in extending a
hand to make possible the healing of
long-held hurts
at the very beginning of her life of
service the queen made a pledge
to dedicate herself to her country and
her people
and to maintain the principles of
constitutional government
This Promise she kept with steadfast
faith
now with that shining example before me
and with God's help
I take up my new duties resolved to seek
the welfare of all the inhabitants of
Northern Ireland
during the years of my mother's reign
it has been a privilege to Bear witness
to such a devoted life
may it be granted to us all
to fulfill the tasks before us so well
thank you
foreign